the Internet is going crazy over this
fraction if you look at its decimal
representation every 24-bit string has a
Fibonacci number in order why is this
fraction generating the Fibonacci
numbers what's going on
and by Fibonacci number we mean a
sequence described by Pingala more than
a thousand years before to answer this
mystery we'll look at a seemingly
unrelated question what is 1 divided by
the polynomial 1 minus X minus x squared
we can do this by long division
our first quotient will be 1 and then
we'll subtract out and we'll be left
with the result X plus x squared this
gives our next quotient of X which we
then subtract out we have 2x squared
plus X cubed so our next term will be
plus 2x squared subtracting that out we
have 3x cubed plus 2x to the fourth so
our next term will be plus 3x to the
cubed to eliminate the 3x cubed when we
do that subtraction we end up with 5x to
the 4th plus 3x to the fifth
so our next term will be 5x to the
fourth and now we're seeing a pattern in
the coefficients of this polynomial if
we write f to the N as the nth Fibonacci
term we have 1 divided by this
polynomial will be f1 plus X times F of
2 plus X cubed times F of 3 plus X cubed
times F of 4 and so on each new power of
X will be associated with the next term
of the Fibonacci sequence so how is this
going to help us solve the mystery well
let's use a simple
and special value for X let's use X is
equal to 10 to the power of negative 24
or this is 1 divided by 10 to the power
24 and what's interesting is you can use
different values of X here so in our
problem we had 24 bit strings that were
the Fibonacci numbers but you can
experiment on your own and try and
figure out different values of X when
you substitute this value in you end up
with this quotient which will then
simplify to this following fraction if
you calculate what's in the denominator
you end up with that crazy number with
all the nines and 1/8 in the middle and
the only difference between this number
and what we originally what we want is
we need to divide this by 10 to the
power of 48 which is x squared with our
value of X so then we end up with the
exact fraction that we started out with
that crazy fraction and we know from
what we just derived this will be equal
to what we this this series of X of
powers of X associated with Fibonacci
numbers shifted over by two powers of X
in other words we figured out that this
crazy fraction is equal to the following
infinite series if we write this using X
is equal to 10 to the power of negative
24 we end up with the following
expression so this means every twenty
four terms we're going to get a new
Fibonacci number and that's exactly what
we had at the beginning so that's why we
end up with this crazy representation
and one thing I'm going to leave you
with is obviously this is a rational
number so once you get to the point
where all 24 numbers all 24 bits are
filled up it actually breaks the pattern
and eventually this is going to repeat
you're not going to keep getting the
Fibonacci numbers infinitely many times
because this is a rational number the
decimal is going to repeat but you can
try different values of x and that's why
this formula comes up
I hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can also catch me at presh
tall Locker on social media and if you
like this video please check out my
books there's links in the video
description thanks for watching